we're gonna check out JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure all-star battle this is a
fighting game from I believe it's Bandai
Namco now not Namco Bandai but it came
out in Japan middle of last year and
it's finally get finally getting a
release here in the States and if you
guys don't think this game is awesome
let me go ahead and put those fears
aside right now putting sapele against
the Pelley yeah we're good it's a sapele
family battle royale but this is by far
one of the best parts thing is this game
to go to Ronnie James Dio is Magic part
of the cyberconnect2 family of games
cyberconnect2 best known for their
stewardship of the Naruto video games
and of the dog hack yes end of dot hack
fame on they made great character
centric brawlers and this is the latest
in that this came out in August last
year in Japan Japan so okay first off I
mean one he's got a checkered top hat
was amazed to I didn't get off my horse
didn't realize that I'd be riding my
horse and throwing my steel balls or
knocked me off the horse my horse is
gonna evaporate out into the wild there
what might see a little bit more of him
later but JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
all-star battle a pretty simple and
straightforward fighting game really as
fighting games go the visuals are really
the most crazy probably and of course
when you knock somebody down you got a
time imagine how bad that would hurt all
right that would hurt so bad to have
like your name engraved on your teeth
got a grill it yeah oh it's like oh okay
I just assumed they were engraved
straight on the big guy stuff alright so
blank slate here okay I know it sat in
the bed this game nobody knows that we
went on by JoJo's you wanna know about
the game JoJo's Bizarre Adventure is an
anime manga entertainment franchise and
not surprised big in Japan if you can
believe that since the late 80s but we
really didn't know about it much here in
the States until the mid nineties when
Capcom
a fantastic 2d fighting game by the same
name that is available now as an HD
update originally came out ps2 and
Dreamcast I believe but now you can get
the HD version I really want to do some
more stuff in my course bear support le
I wanna remind of folks at home I'm sure
they have questions if they have any
questions about Jojo and he's out on
earth South Asia please put them in the
comments on GameSpot in the twitch chat
or use hashtag oh no I did my silence on
the Twitter but yeah so pankot releases
is fantastic 2d fighting game back in
the 90s and we really haven't seen much
more Jojo some of the characters have
appeared like in crossover anime
fighting games before but they really I
don't think they've had at least here in
the states I dedicated a game of
ultimate cells until all-star battle
which was fired I did get retired look
at how and he's pouring one out for me
there I appreciate that they also do a
whole lot of this this is like a big
part of JoJo's Laura's giving crazy
things with your arms and hands let's
see some more so that that was sort of
that was a warm-up introductory bout I
want to see you get in it oh yeah well
you've given on this Jojen you put your
Jojo bout all right let's go back we're
have to go all the way back to mode
select so I can set it to player V let's
have a look at some of the characters
cuz apparently this has all REO
speedwagon's well I offer ito Speedwagon
ya don't even question it okay I don't
even cries we're gonna do two flavors
okay I don't have all the characters
unlocked unfortunately I just got this
in a couple of days ago so I haven't had
the do reference seemed like a stretch
all right who else we got here okay
let's play a game called what is this
dudes deal so this guy seems alright
what is this news deal what is this
dudes deal wait what is he holding
Rainbow Road it's the Rainbow Road it is
a place that you go I found my character
it's Hermes costo some sort of robot
with bit like a three-year-old with
kissy stickers get access to and just
started just started sticking them up
around is this like some sort of cowboy
future where people are named themselves
after 80s classic rock I would like to
think so do
well go higher than a hundred percent no
not anthem Jonathan I could have I could
have gone lower than by the way normal a
normal outfit
totally normal nothing to be surprised
by all right so I'm presuming that my
Musa consists of head butts you can
great wit actually you got it basically
square triangle circle those are your
three attacks yep and you're gonna use
r1 to summon your imaginary friend my
friend names which makes sense is the
second is it a horse I wish it was
unfortunately I believe there are only
two mounted characters two cared what's
the other one roses we can see the other
one here in a second
oh yeah vase of action I'm just gonna
dumb this to do a couple of like
stretches here and just get warmed up
first work the knees a little bit
yeah let's dive right into it on this
game basically at its most basic you can
just use the square button you just tap
it out square button to do a sort of
persona 4 arena style Auto combo so
we're the honestly that was four pushes
the square bun you if you want to give
that a shot that's one two three four
there you go boom just like that nice
Auto comment I do the other thing uh
Naruto friend knives oh wow so if you
want to say guess this might just
possibly be if you want to summit so you
can bring out your imaginary friend to
do specialist Menace the crap out here
we go gonna flinch first who's gonna
flinch first oh gosh
walk backwards walk away from each other
all you want to see the back wall hold
on I gotta do a little I gotta check out
your situation i'm peacing out coming
after you no no you want to go in oh
yeah that's actually that right there
that's actually a move on my part where
I walk towards you intimidate it's a
heart attack where if you hit me I will
I will counter again but you're not
gonna take you to get some of this yeah
this kind of reminds me of those kids
that live up in the mission you see a
lot of people just like oh sorry what
this is thinkin of the kids that live in
the mission this is a stage gimmick
you'll notice there was like that big
red pulsating thing on the ground a
second ago oh I tried to get you to get
run over by that guy but basically what
happened that guy was frightening if you
uh if
knock somebody down onto one of those
pulsating areas it will trigger it the
stage gimmick for that stage you should
probably do that then I guess well it's
already happened so this is anime as
hell oh it's so anime and once the stage
gimmick is triggered basically and
unblockable dude is gonna run out oh
you're doing the boom yeah did I just
split your soul in Twain uh you're
creating a Horcrux right now oh and you
got my ear you pull pull the nickel out
of my ear oh just like some dudes Bank
now I walk away fans of this series must
absolutely love this this just seems
like it's so tied into what's going on
ah with fans of this it does do a great
job of capturing the insane Jojo style I
will say when the game first came out in
Japan there were also Bandai Namco's
been experimenting a lot with involving
free-to-play elements into other games
like they have tekken revolution
completely free to play this game was
still the full retail release but also
had a lot of free-to-play elements to it
that earth a lot of people okay so since
then they've sort of scaled back on a
lot of those things um so hopefully I
haven't been able to go in and try out
those elements yet cuz I basically just
playing versus since we got it um
hopefully a lot of that will be a little
bit of the dollar sign in chests I feel
like I should play as hands well
suddenly there's a straight mauler some
of the chat was I'm not sure if they're
making it up or not but some of the chat
was saying that there's a vanilla ice in
this there is a vanilla IC somewhere
like down in this fish I had him unlock
before he started to think I tried to
log as many characters as like good
you'll notice all of the characters I
unlocked come from the start you guys
don't know this whatever come from the
Stardust Crusaders story arc which is
the story arc that the Capcom game that
came out in the 90s was faithful I did
notice that much I hear this is pulling
in people from Asia this is or even
people from all over JoJo's lore there's
so much JoJo's out there I really I
could tell you a little bit about
Stardust Crusaders it's basically kind
of a Castlevania situation where they a
lineage of people the Joestar family if
you will who their ancestors keep going
on these bizarre adventures doctors to
name JoJo's bizarre adventures in these
starters Crusader Ark we have Jotaro
otherwise known as Jojo who is going to
battle an immortal
empire whose stolen his great-great
grand Pappy's body okay not joe joestar
that no joseph joestar joseph joestar is
a different character than jonathan
sicker but i have i have no idea
this is dollar dollar bills y'all
abilities we are Sudanese and I wouldn't
be surprised if that was actually his
name can you do the the stage the stage
gimmick for this one I think it out
goodness I'm not entirely I know that so
this is the Philadelphia coast stage
right and actually yeah obvious yeah as
you can tell Albert this stage is unique
in that the stage gimmick for this one
is actually it actually helps the person
that it that it hits I think either
heals you it gives you something smells
you a [ __ ]
so I'm beating you up and your
self-esteem is taking a mean hit also
something a point that I wanted to know
back when I did that taunt earlier I'll
try to do another one here we go I'm
knock you down real quick know and do a
quick time OMA dick yes I am looking on
sweating it basically how do I do a ton
taan sport okay alright so use are to to
grab me and then when I fall down hit
the select button can you guys walk the
words eat salt there you go yeah you
know it's a special time because the
camera like zooms and I know and so what
tonsil do is they'll either put that
either put a buff on yourself or they'll
put a debuff on your opponent or they'll
give you some extra meter or we can walk
away from each other I love your sound
effects like well I cannot handle like
you know do not stand very go forward
you're not stepped to me right now
if you popping off these game you pop it
off there's not a person in this game
that I would not cross the screen if I
saw them walking towards me
oh no I'm mildly on fire crossfire
hurricane alright folks whoever wins
this round wins the game alright well I
got you in the crossfire right now is
our adventure
oh they didn't quite do I've been caught
up in the crossfire we aren't just about
tied up oh no you might suck on this
oh and you hit me into the no bear sign
oh oh now the Bears are gonna give
mattock fit what a traumatic yeah
vandalism I like it JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure when's it coming out JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure all-star batter comes
out next week I said that a little weird
didn't jump out next week exclusively
for the PlayStation 3 home entertainment
computer says I like it